The Legend of Zelda is in an odd spot at
the moment it's not broken per se but it
is very different from what the series
used to be and because of this we've got
fans on the one side defending it to the
death and we've got fans on the other
side attacking it to the death now
watching my recent videos you might
think I'm one of the ladder but you'd
actually be surprised my take on the
current state of Zelda is quite simple I
defend the parts of the games that I
like and criticize the parts that I
don't there are definitely fans on
either side of this argument that are
much more passionate about their side
than I am but no matter what side you're
on if you're watching this right now you
can breathe a sigh of
relief big Bandits here to fix all this
I believe there exists an idea for the
next Zelda game that if implemented
would appease both attackers and
Defenders of the current Legend of Zelda
20 ideas to be specific let us begin
number one I think it would be a good
idea to rework the current weapon system
I've never been one of those people that
absolutely despises the weapon system
that was introduced in breath of the the
wild I think that this is a fine Concept
in and of itself I think that a lot of
other open world games use the same kind
of durability concept for their weapons
I just think that it could be massively
improved upon I think Nintendo needs to
rebalance it from the ground up I think
that more powerful weapons need to be a
lot more rare to find and consequently I
think that weapons need to have a lot
more durability just on average I'm not
saying that every bobblin out there
that's carrying a booat should no longer
drop their booat that would be
unrealistic and I actually like the fact
that if you can see an enemy using a
weapon they drop said weapon that's a
great gameplay mechanic in my opinion
what I'm saying is that there should be
a lot fewer more powerful weapons out
there giving players fewer more powerful
weapons would make those weapons a lot
more valuable and subsequently I think
the same kind of thing could be
implemented for tears of the Kingdom's
new weapon system which is to say the
forging system I love it personally it's
just simple enough to keep things fresh
I just think again that they could do a
lot more with it maybe multiple items
can be fused into a weapon maybe there
can be more effects than what we've
currently seen maybe some items fused
onto a weapon can repair that weapon
some items fused onto a weapon can
increase its durability or you can
combine a durability increase with an
electric mushroom something like that to
zap your enemies but also keep your
weapon for longer the possible
combinations would be endless but
speaking of new combinations and new
weapons what if the new Zelda game
introduced new weapons entirely so in
breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom there are three kinds of melee
weapons one-handed two-handed quick and
two-handed slow and yes link will swing
them at different speeds or maybe
slightly different lead depending on
like if you have a blunt weapon as
opposed to a sharpened weapon but that
doesn't change the fact that there are
only three very basic weapon types out
there I would love to see link able to
wield of course Spears and swords but
what about bigger swords or smaller
swords like daggers what about dual
wielding what about hammers or a giant
mace what about a Ballin chain or a
smaller handheld one called a Morning
Star what about a whip what about new
kinds of bows like like great bows or
crossbows and here's a thought that I'll
kind of go into a little bit more later
on but what about introducing new
legendary weapons for link to wield what
if for instance you could stumble across
ganon's Trident and these other
legendary weapons would Grant special
abilities and I know I've been rambling
about weapons for a while and trust me
the other points on this list are not
going to take nearly this much time but
weapons is such a broad subject I really
needed to just put all my thoughts out
there the last thing I'll say about it
is I think that weapons should be
repairable I think this is something
that people have complained about since
breath of the wild in 2017 and it's
definitely something that should have
been an addition to tears of the Kingdom
which was not sadly I understand that
Nintendo felt that being able to repair
your weapons would hurt the mechanic
that they were going for which is
continually just keep exploring keep
finding weapons keep swapping to new
ones and whatnot but if you implement a
durability mechanic that could
accomplish the same thing sure you might
have a great weapon sure you might
really like using that weapon sure it
might have cost you an arm and a leg to
get that weapon but once its durability
hits zero you can't use it anymore got
to go get it repaired and in the
meantime you have to find the other
weapons that you've picked up it could
work it should work and it would
definitely help fix the next Legend of
Zelda for everybody next up speaking of
reworking things I think that the entire
eating mechanic in Zelda should be
reworked I do enjoy the addition of Link
being able to eat things in order to
regenerate health and Achieve different
status effects but we've got to be
honest with ourselves the moment that
they introduced Health regeneration as a
solely making link eat things mechanic
they removed collecting hearts and this
might be my Nostalgia talking or it
might just be the argument of a
different style of game but I kind of
miss having to look for hearts
furthermore I think that giving link the
ability to just pause the game at any
point and eat 1 million apples at any
given point and regenerate unlimited
amounts of Health was kind of a change
for the worse it made things a bit too
too easy the only real way that you'll
get killed in this game is if you fall
off of something or if something hits
you hard enough in the older Zelda games
if you were really struggling with a
fight and you were out of potions or you
just couldn't find any hearts around you
all the pots were gone the grass was
gone the smaller enemies to kill for
hearts were all gone then you were kind
of out of luck but it's tricky because I
on the other hand do enjoy all of the
various cooking and effects that link is
able to get from eating things in breath
of the wild and tears of the Kingdom so
what do we do in the next Zelda game to
implement maybe both of these systems
well I'm glad you asked for one example
of how to handle this I would like to
reference genin impact now for those of
you who have played the game you
probably know what I'm talking about but
if you haven't in genin Impact it has a
very similar pause the game eat
something to regenerate your
characters's health mechanic however
your characters can't just eat a million
things at any given point they have an
appetite and if they're full and can't
eat anymore then they're full and they
can't eat anymore therefore it's a hard
cap on how many things you can stuff
down the gullet of your characters it is
a little odd that link can eat 500
apples 200 mushrooms and three
multi-course meals in any given instant
I mean I'm sure he's got a fast
metabolism but that's a little freaky
and maybe we could flesh this out a
little bit more maybe not all meals are
created equal maybe a smaller just
chicken on a stick meal could take up
this much of his appetite but a full
coar big Grand turkey could take up this
much of his appetite and the effects
would differ as as well this only
regenerates one heart this regenerates
five and in the meantime you could also
find hearts in Grass pots or on minor
enemies all over Hyrule I could see it
working very well actually and potions
on the other hand could not take up any
appetite because you know you can always
drink right number three and perhaps the
most obvious of all of them we need a
new map traversing this current land of
Hyrule has been fun and it's so big and
so vast that they even used it again in
tears of the Kingdom just with some
added sky islands and an added depths
area The Legend of Zelda has always had
a day night cycle at least ever since
ocarine of time but you know what none
of the Zelda games have ever had and
I'll get a bit more into this a bit
later on they've never had seasons and I
think this is because there have always
been the winter areas the summer areas
in the same map of Hyrule what if there
are multiple maps that you can travel in
between multiple States if you will and
here's another thing about the new map
that we're going to need going forward
should Link's Spider-Man climbing
ability return if you think about it it
affects everything it affects how
intricately Nintendo designs every
single angle of their Maps it affects
puzzle design and many more factors of
the game personally I don't think that
it's necessary I have enjoyed climbing
ever so slowly up the side of whatever
in the world I wanted to if I had enough
cooked Stam shrooms in my bag but at the
same time there is an Irreplaceable
mechanic that is lost when anything can
be scaled it's the very mechanic that
they inject back into the games whenever
link does a shrine for instance Nintendo
just said nope you can no longer climb
in here because if you can climb over
everything that ruins like half of the
puzzle ideas out there so I see there as
being several benefits to removing
Spider-Man climbing for Link in the next
Zelda game Nintendo can take more time
to focus on designing other elements of
the game or they can take more time to
design more maps in general while not
necessarily having to design it with
quite as much verticality as they did
every single inch in the current world
of Hyrule another slight thing that I
would like to see in the next map
wherever it may be Hyrule or not is the
addition of wandering bosses think about
it we've got World bosses already and
they've been implemented very well you
can Target exactly where a Glock is
exactly where a hinox is exactly where a
stone Talis is if they do roam it's
within their little section I understand
that that might be more difficult in
general but it would be pretty cool it
would make the world feel really alive
for an example of a game that
accomplishes this very well think of
Elden ring and yes Elden ring is a
significantly more difficult game than
Zelda ever has been but the concept
could still be implemented I think in a
way that's not quite as inaccessible for
casual gamers number four another very
big one that's close to my heart bring
back pieces of heart I understand why
they removed pieces of heart from the
game because they wanted to make a
purchasable system for heart containers
and stamina vessels which worked but let
me paint you a picture imagine you walk
into a village let's call it kakaro
Village and you walk into a house and in
the corner of this house there's a cage
and Inside the Cage is a cow and a piece
of heart it's right there you can't
enter the cage though how do you get it
you're left to wonder and puzzle and
think outside the box and this isn't
even a dungeon puzzle this is just in
the world of Hyrule somewhere that very
scenario that I just painted is one of
the most famous pieces of heart to
collect in Ocarina of Time in kakaro
village and it is a staple of the Zelda
series something being dangled right in
front of you just Out Of Reach that
you'll have to think very hard about how
to get to and I think that they could be
added back to the next Zelda game even
if Nintendo wanted to bring back this
multi hundred shrin setup that they have
loved since breath of the wild let's say
there are 200 new shrines in the next
game what if at the end of each of them
they don't each give you the same thing
an orb of blessing or an orb of light or
whatever they're called but instead some
of them will give you a piece of heart
and some of them will give you a piece
of stamina and some would give you other
rewards entirely very rare weapons very
rare potions rare pieces of gear and
they could also add back in pieces of
heart in the world of hyru at large put
one in a tree have a flying enemy around
carrying one in their talons and you got
to figure out how to get up to it and
knock it down and leave the solution up
to the player adding pieces of heart
back into the game could work so easily
and should work and would still appease
all kinds of fans out there number five
one of the most requested things since
breath of the wild came out the return
of dungeons I know what you're thinking
but Bandit didn't they bring dungeons
back in tears of the Kingdom no well
they did I guess but you know they were
just the same as the Divine beasts and I
guess you could call them dungeons but
when people ask for the return of Zelda
dungeons they're talking about much
longer experiences that are much more
notable much more memorable with a lot
more puzzles involved but I'm not just
slamming my fists on the table like an
old nostalgic fan saying bring me back
what I was used to I don't like this new
stuff I'm here to tell you what if they
brought back dungeons in a new way here
are a couple ideas branching off of that
Seasons changing idea that I had a
little bit ago what if some dungeons
were ephemeral which is to say
temporarily accessible imagine there's a
dungeon on top of the frozen icy
mountain and you can only access it in
the spring summer or fall because in
Winter it is way too cold to go up there
the entire pathway is just iced over and
believe it or not link can no longer
just climb up the side of Frozen
freaking ice anymore and it's way too
cold for any fire to melt it or what if
the dungeon underneath Death Mountain is
only accessible in the winter because in
the spring summer or fall things are
just way too hot link skin sets on fire
just trying to enter the area or get
this what if there's a Temple that just
so happens to be underwater that's only
accessible in the spring or the fall
maybe this Lake that it's positioned in
is in between de mountain and the icy
mountain and in the summer it's too hot
to enter the water and in the winter the
water freezes over and that's just one
element of ephemeral dungeons there
could be dungeons that slip in and out
of time there could be dungeons that
slip in and out of reality there could
be dungeons that will levitate into the
sky for some jargon lore reason I'm just
saying if you brought in ephemeral
dungeons that would shake things up
quite a bit and here's another way to
implement new dungeons do you know what
a Rog like is for those of you who don't
a Rog like game is a game that's
essentially a Dungeon Crawler but every
level that you enter has randomized
enemies and therefore randomized loot
that is temporary for that run you get
as far into it as you can and often
times there is an end there is a last
level a last boss and that may or may
not be randomized but if you fail you
reset your progress all the way to the
start and you lose all of your temporary
Buffs that you were collecting along the
way what if the Legend of Zelda had a
rogu likee dungeon think the master
sword trials but randomized and there
are so many ways to fit a rogu likee
dungeon into the lore but I digress the
next thing that could fix the next
Legend of Zelda would be new playable
modes SL situations SL events that break
up the monotonous gameplay so here's
what I mean by that in breath of the
wild and tears of the Kingdom you play
your first segment of the game where it
teaches you the mechanics of the game
you get your powers that you'll use in
the game and that's it you use this same
style of gameplay this formula that you
have learned for link in every Circle
cumstance but in past Zelda games
Twilight Princess for instance there
were so many different spots where the
game play was broken up to introduce
something urgent or just different like
spoiler alert for the game Sorry but
there is a moment in the game where you
have to save midna's life she's on your
back dying you have to race to the
castle or when you have to do the escort
mission for the dying Zora Prince or
when you have the duels on the bridge
leading to the most kickass shot of Link
in the ENT entire franchise to date
breath of the wild and tears of the
kingdom do have some of these broken up
modes of gameplay but normally they're
related to maybe a side quest or
something like that I would like to see
a bit more grandure of a concept being
enacted for maybe the main story or
something along those lines number seven
we need active companions to make a
return I'm talking na'vi from Ocarina of
Time I'm talking midna from Twilight
Princess I'm talking the king of red
lions from Wind Waker I'm talking fee
from Skyward Sword for most of the most
popular Zelda games out there link has a
companion this companion character gives
advice comments on things tells link
what to do reminds him what his current
status is again to reference a game that
enacts this very Concept in a very
wellth thought out way albe yet I'm not
the biggest fan of this character genin
impacts Pimon that's an open world game
that has a bunch of quests and different
things that you can do but Pyon follows
you around everywhere and comments on
everything and doesn't stop I'm not
saying the character has to be annoying
I'm just saying that it would be nice to
have a companion character and here's
another element to that what if you
could choose your companion character
what if there were a bunch of choices
like the older companions from The
Legend of Zelda franchise midna na'vi
fee and you could choose which one of
them you want to explore the world with
and each of them had unique things they
would say and unique pieces of dialogue
prompting you to really try each of them
out and different relationships with
link or you could choose to have none of
them and just go alone without anybody
talking in your ear I think everybody
would be a fan of that idea Nintendo
number eight new or old lore now if that
sounds confusing good the reason why I
said that is because this would be the
only way to appease everybody in onef
swoop and all it takes Nintendo if
you're listening is to make a choice
either a connect the lore from the next
Zelda game to the franchise not
connecting all the pieces but leaving
pieces to be connected that makes sense
or be don't connect anything at all do
something new entirely have the only
reference to previous Zelda games be the
existence of Link and Zelda choose one
or the other of these approaches to the
story and lore of the next game but do
not sacrifice a good narrative trying to
do both and honestly personally I'm
leaning more towards the side of do
something new entirely I mean it's very
obvious isn't it breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom aren't even
connected to the timeline they've
already set the building blocks up to
separate the next Zelda game entirely
from everything that came before so
honestly I think they should number nine
I believe everybody would benefit from
the appearance of a new villain the
Zelda series will most likely never come
out from under the shadow of Ganon he's
iconic he's big he's scary he's
beautiful we love him but I'm going to
level with you here Ganon or Ganon Dwarf
as a character is now generic in every
way in the first place he's not just one
character anymore he's multiple he can
reincarnate as another version of
himself so therefore it's not Ganondorf
it's a Ganondorf and secondly and this
one is a bit more factual Ganondorf
doesn't have to have a backstory he can
just show up and be I hate Hyrule I want
to take everything for myself because
that is what a king must do which is the
most generic villain thing I've ever
heard so let's not ruin his legacy or do
something with it that would piss
anybody off let's just introduce a new
villain new villains have been
introduced in the series before and
typically they go over pretty well you
look at me right now and tell me you did
not absolutely adore
girim I know you did girim was amazing
and gim's relation to demise was amazing
everybody loved Zant of course some
people have complaints about how he
turned out at the end but everybody
loved Zant even the non-cannon villains
like what's his face asor he was pretty
freaking cool madus vati Yuga the list
goes on and on and I think that
everybody would benefit from a new Zelda
villain number 10 the return of
underwater gameplay honestly I don't
think I even need to go into this all
that much enough said I think everybody
whether a defender or an attacker of the
current state of Zelda games misses
underwater traversal it was one of the
weirdest things to remove from the era
of the wild although everybody
understands why it's simply because it
would have been too much for the
development team but I don't know about
you I would trade probably a good half
of the map of Hyrule if it meant good
old-fashioned underwater puzzles
dungeons traversal you name it combat
whatever bring it back Nintendo bring it
back number 11 I don't I don't have
enough fingers for any of the other ones
meaningful items listen for you new
Zelda fans there used to be meaningful
gadgets and spells and tools back in the
day that link could use I'm talking the
shovel the spinner Ballin chain Pegasus
Boots the power bracelet magical rods
masks the hook shot the gust Bellows
each of these served to enhance the
gameplay unlock new areas new methods of
combat methods of traversal you name it
and were all replaced for Link's arsenal
of sandbox powers like magnesis or
ultrahand but I think especially if
Nintendo were to do what I was talking
about earlier and remove Link's
Spider-Man crawling ability ities that
it would be a very welcome addition
especially for traversal and think about
the musical instruments oh man link used
to have such cool musical instruments in
in addition to the Ocarina IM maur's
mask he had a guitar he had drums he had
a bagpipe things in sky sword he had a
harp in Twilight Princess he could Howl
in Wind Waker he had the Wind Waker
which was a baton that could conduct the
notes of the wind and each of these
magical instruments were used for
warping were used for changing night to
day or day to night calling upon a storm
you name it I think link should have a
musical instrument in the next game
maybe one that he can choose I think
that magic should return so in breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom right
you pick up a fire arrow you fire that
fire arrow now you have no fire arrows
in the older Zelda games you learned the
ability to magically create fire arrows
and you could fire them out there so
long as you had arrows and magic and
bringing magic back would open the door
to all sorts of different spells you
could bring back Ocarina of Time style
spells like Den's fire or you could
introduce new ones like imagine if link
could heal himself with magic power I
find it very hard to imagine the kind of
person that would have a problem with
this addition in the next Zelda game
number 12 bring back empty bottles empty
bottles were a whole other mechanic
that's just not there at all in breath
of the wild or tears of the kingdom and
you can still have your magical
unlimited inventory but bottles were at
least one form of inventory management
that actually made sense and that nobody
had a problem with you had to choose
whether or not you wanted to store a
health potion or a magic potion or a
potion very expensive that would restore
both or if you wanted to catch a fairy
or back in aine of time if you wanted to
catch some bugs or if you wanted to
catch a fish or if you wanted to catch
some water it was an inventory mechanic
that was cool and I think it should be
brought back and also they were powerful
enough to defeat Ganondorf yeah bring
them back number 13 a playable story you
know what I mean by that in breath of
the wild you don't play through the
story like we all thought we were going
to when we first saw the trailers no all
of that happened 100 years prior to the
games events now we've all cried over it
if we were going to cry over it or not
that's been a long time ago and it's not
that breath of the Wild's story was not
good it was it was actually it was great
I just did a video covering the the
kings of Hyrule and when I covered ran
BOS fama's Hyrule I got sad because it's
a really good story but we didn't get to
play through it and when tears of the
Kingdom came out they kind of teased us
a little bit with Ganondorf being right
there in front of Lincoln Zelda after
the events of breath of the wild meaning
this is something that's going to be
happening as of our control of the
characters of the game and it starts and
you see Ganondorf and things happen and
then everything already happened in the
past exact L like breath of the wild you
do not get to play through it you do not
get to experience any of it you just
find it out again and if you think about
it the last time that a Zelda game had a
story that had events that you actually
play through was over 10 years ago in A
Link Between Worlds it's been over a
decade it's time and speaking of the
story number 14 give us a linear and
nonlinear combo of gameplay that can
actually work it's a very simple concept
that they've been implementing ever
since ever since the start to be honest
with you think about a link to the past
how many nonlinear things can you do at
any point in the game play that just
pauses the linear story and doesn't
affect its progression they did the same
thing in Ocarina they did the same thing
in Majora's Mask they did the same thing
in Wind Waker they did the same thing in
Twilight Princess they did the same
thing in skyd sword and it's not just
Zelda games most open world games do
this Oblivion Skyrim The Fallout games
even MMOs World of Warcraft Final
Fantasy Elden ring this is however one
that I'm not sure that anuma will be
very open to in a recent interview as
you might remember he stated that he
doesn't really want there to be stories
in games anymore and I'm not sure if
this was taken out of context or what
but it's definitely a strange take that
does kind of makes sense given his
decisions with the stories in the last
few years he wants there to be a story
that players kind of make themselves in
a sandbox world like I said it could
have been taken out of context so I'm
just going to put a pin in that and not
come back to it but speaking speaking of
a create your own concept though number
15 what if the next Zelda game
implemented a diverging storyline the
era of the Wild games have already had
multiple endings depending on how many
things you completed in the game what if
this was just an evolution of that
concept again to reference another game
series that does this very well the
souls series Elden ring Dark Souls
bloodborne demon souls or heck the Five
Nights at Freddy's games there are
always multiple endings that depend on
your choices even though there's only
ever won that's actually the cannon
ending it still doesn't matter though
because it feels rewarding to a player
to have a different path through the
game as another player that was
different because of your choices I'm
not saying you should be able to make
link a villain unless Nintendo really
wanted to think outside the box for the
next game but the ability to alter what
does or doesn't happen by The Game's end
might be a very welcome addition let the
players create their own stories right
number 16 we need a lot more enemies I
know that tears of the Kingdom brought
some new enemies into the fold like the
flux constructs or the froes or the gleo
I kind of don't want to do this because
I'm not that proud of this video but in
a relatively recent retrospective I did
about breath of the wild I compared the
number of different kinds of monsters
that you can encounter in breath of the
wild two other Zelda games and I'm just
going to let you have a listen to that
early game you get used to fighting any
one of these kinds of enemies the only
real difference between their colors is
their health pool here's a little frame
of reference for you in breath of the
wild and I'm going to refer to my notes
Here There are 988 total different
enemies that includes World bosses and
all the versions of Ganon as well but
when you cut out the duplicates like you
know the multiple colors or the multiple
different kinds of the same enemy that
are just different elements you are left
with 28 different kinds of enemies in
the game for comparison in ocarine of
time you know a game that came out 19
years before breath of the wild there
were 87 total different enemies in the
game or 6 four when you cut out the
duplicates that's well over twice the
amount of unique enemies in breath of
the wild in Twilight Princess which came
out 12 years before breath of the wild
there were 107 total enemies or 84
unique different kinds of enemies when
you cut out the duplicates that is
literally three times the amount in
breath of the wild but yet breath
of my point is we just need a lot more
different kinds of enemies to fight in
the next Zelda game I think this is
something that the series set as a
standard and then kind of went back on
quite a bit because they spent more time
developing the map itself in breath of
the wild and tears of the kingdom and
it's definitely something that can just
be changed they don't even have to
develop a lot of new enemies just bring
back all the old enemies that we've been
missing bring back skulas bring back
stalos bring back tech ties or make new
ones and obviously I could go on for a
while but you get the point on this one
number 17 and this is a technical one
but I would like to to see The Return of
having multiple save files listen this
is something that a lot of games are
implementing these days and I don't know
that Nintendo will ever go back on but
typically these days when you download a
game which most people do these days I I
haven't bought a physical game in years
I don't even know when the last time is
that I bought a physical game it was
probably breath of the wild to be honest
but most people buy digital copies and
download them and when you do download
these games they are linked to your
account not to the console and so
because of that these days a lot of
games don't let you have multiple save
files they're linked to your account you
launch that game it's your one save file
and breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom implement this wholeheartedly
the reason why game companies are doing
this is because it is so easy to just
generate multiple sales if you have a
family that wants to play breath of the
wild and multiple members of that family
want to play breath of the Wild on their
own and you haven't bought the physical
version then you're going to need a
separate $60 copy for every single
person that wants to play the game but
when Zelda had saved files you were able
to re-experience the game without having
to erase all of your progress and maybe
be a bit more experimental in your next
playthroughs or share it with friends or
family members who wanted to try the
game but you didn't want to wipe your
game for it it would be nice to see save
files come back stay with me here we're
in the last few number 18 I think that
it could be an entirely new setting and
by that I mean I mean that
wholeheartedly I mean it doesn't even
have to be Hyrule or maybe it does but
it doesn't have to be a game that is
about link saving Zelda from the
clutches of whoever anymore it could be
a gudo adventure with an entirely
different set of characters from the
ground up maybe they don't mess with the
balance of Link Zelda and Ganondorf
maybe this isn't about the Triforce
which you know it hasn't been about the
Triforce in 10 years anyway maybe we
need an entire new set of characters for
a Mainline game and I know what you're
thinking at that point what is keeping
it a Legend of Zelda game well let me
raise the question to you what is
keeping it a Legend of Zelda game these
days there's no Triforce there are no
pieces of heart the things that we do
recognize from molder Zelda games are
all different like the master sword for
instance and everything is weirdly just
like a reference and not actually can to
the game we simply have Link and Zelda
that connect it to the other Zelda games
they've been thinking outside the box
it's something I could see happening in
the next Zelda game and it's something
that I think would only have a little
bit of complaint at first but once we
all knew and understood that it was
going to be a completely new story with
completely new characters that is
somehow otherwise connected to the
Legend of Zelda maybe it's just simply
in the same universe I think everybody
would accept it and everybody would love
it given that the narrative and gameplay
are good of course number
19 listen this one's going to sound
crazy but keep thinking about it we need
more mounts for link think about it in
breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom you could already go and get
multiple horses but you know what horses
have in common they're all horses the
slowest one and the fastest one are both
still horses what if link could have a
flying Mount like a loft Wing maybe it
could fly but it wasn't as fast on the
ground making it more convenient for him
to switch from a horse to his Loft wing
and what if he had underwater mounts as
well what if he could ride one of those
giant seahorses like the ones that we
saw in skyd sword or be tugged by a
manay or a I don't know a baby jabu jabu
and you could further this idea with
gear for your mounts that would actually
enhance their speed or stamina and and
customize their colorations and patterns
and whatever I think that would be a
huge W for everybody before we get to
number 20 which is going to be my last
point that I'll talk about I'm going to
give an honorable mention I think that
we need to rework the art style from the
ground up I think that Zelda has spent a
long time being very cartoony ever since
the prevalence of super cartoony
Graphics in like the wind waker which if
you'll recall had such a bad backlash
over its graphical style that in
Twilight Princess which was going to be
Wind Waker 2 as according to the files
of the game they completely overhauled
it and made it the most realistic
looking Zelda game and people really
liked it it was very popular it was
rated te and I get that Nintendo is not
necessarily trying to not Market to kids
anymore but they need to remember that a
huge huge huge portion of their fans are
my age or or older that is to say within
the 20 to 40 age Zone we don't mind
realistic looking Graphics in fact we
probably would enjoy it quite a bit but
here's the other thing about that having
realistic Graphics in a video game
requires better Hardware to be honest
which is kind of why they decided to go
with the graphical style that they did
for breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom that's the only way to pull off
those vast fields of grass but hey
depending on whether or not you believe
believe it apparently we might be
getting the switch successor this year
so let's see what that's all about right
I swear if it's just like here's the
switch OLED part to a little bit better
of a screen and a little bit better
speakers I I'm going to I think I'm
going to Riot but anyway the last thing
that I think would be a w across the
board that would make the Legend of
Zelda better than ever number 20 we need
an actual crafting system listen cooking
in the era of the wild feels really good
but I think we could enhance cooking I
think we could bring crafting as a whole
to crafting gear repairing your armor
crafting weapons imagine that cooking
returns but it's not just five
ingredients that go into whatever dish
you're trying to make not all
ingredients are created equal right why
should a whole ass turkey take up the
same ingredient slot as salt what if we
had two protein sections and two or
three like filler sections and then like
two or three uh garnishes Each of which
we could fill or not fill that would
enhance multiple kinds of status effects
for link upon consumption giving us a
system like this would enable us to get
as complex with it as we wanted or as
simple with it as we wanted which is
very important and Telltale good game
design and like I was mentioning there
are so many materials to pick up in the
worlds of breath of the wild and tears
of the Kingdom why can we not craft
stuff with this we can already Slaughter
enemies by the dozens and break their
horns off and stick them on weapons and
stab other enemies with them why not
take their bones and craft armor or use
it as material to repair our armor
between fusion and cooking as of Tears
of the Kingdom the elements are there
for a really really wellth thought out
and intuitive and immersive crafting
system I think they just need to go that
extra step and Implement them all and
there you have it my complete list of 20
things that Nintendo should Implement to
fix the Legend of Zelda once and for all
for everybody across the board let me
remind you that Nintendo does listen to
people specifically YouTubers you know
how much influence the zonai had in the
story of breath of the wild B myota you
know how much they had in tears of the
Kingdom actually just everything was zai
I guarantee you that was probably
because of all the chatter we had about
the Zoni on YouTube so if you want
anything in this video implemented in
the next Zelda game give it a like
subscribe to the channel comment below
with what you want to see more
interaction on this video will get it
spread around more so let's see what we
can do and at the very least it'll get
it spread around to other Zelda fans
just like you and me who will begin this
conversation and new and who knows maybe
we could make some of this stuff happen
or hit me up on Instagram and let me
know over there thank you so much for
watching and to my Bandit crew for
supporting the channel and that's all
I've got so as always this is Bandit
looking forward to seeing you in the
next one and signing out
[Music]
peace